ils vont nous prendre deux nos deux plus
belles années de retraite me disaient
une ATSEM de la ville d'Arcueil la
semaine dernière
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire demande par cette question
préalable de rejeter ce texte de loi et
de renvoyer le gouvernement à la
nécessité de reprendre le dialogue avec
les organisations syndicales ne vous en
déplaisent chers collègues ce serait un
message fort adressé à nos concitoyens
massivement opposés à cette réforme un
témoignage de notre écoute de leurs
aspirations et de leurs colères en
repoussant de deux ans l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à la retraite l'objet de ce
texte né en effet ni plus ni moins que
de faire peser l'équilibre du système de
retraite sur le dos des travailleurs
plutôt que sur le capital cette réforme
annonçait initialement comme une réforme
de justice mal mènera en fait nos
concitoyens et d'abord et principalement
les femmes
et bien sûr celles et ceux aussi qui
souffrent au travail celles et ceux dont
le corps et l'outil celles et ceux dont
les gestes répétitifs abîment les
épaules les dos mais aussi celles et
ceux qui vivent dans la tension
permanente du résultat sans plus
reconnaître toujours le sens de leur
travail les Françaises et les Français
nous parlent de leur vie et le
gouvernement répond
compatibilité comptabilité au fond cette
réforme comptable et financière était
déjà annoncé dans cette hémicycle par
Bruno Le Maire à l'occasion de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques non
pour équilibrer le régime des retraites
le système actuel n'est pas en danger
les dépenses ne dérapent pas et des
recettes sont possibles à condition de
l'examiner mais bien pour faire baisser
les dépenses publiques et respecter les
objectifs du pack de stabilité et de
croissance ce qui dérape c'est la dette
publique et elle dérape parce que vous
multipliez les baisses d'impôts
pour les entreprises du CAC 40 dont les
bénéfices battent pourtant tous les
records avec 59,8 milliards de
dividendes versées la France détient le
record d'Europe la seule suppression de
la CVE représente quasiment la totalité
des économies visées par cette réforme
économique vous faites vous payer cash
par les salariés en prenant deux ans de
leur vie cette vision comptable dans un
petit texte rectificatif fait l'impasse
sur la question essentielle celle du
partage de la richesse produite et de
l'accumulation de la richesse pour
quelques-uns
elle fait aussi l'impasse sur l'immense
apport non monétérisé des jeunes
retraités à la société dans les
associations la garde des petits-enfants
les conseils municipaux l'aide aux
parents en fin de vie et d'entendre
autre chose par cette question préalable
nous nous opposons un projet de loi qui
contrairement aux annonces de l'exécutif
ne permettra ni d'équilibrer
financièrement le système ni de garantir
une retraite minimum à 1200 euros
[Musique]